pour être que je vais vous présenter est
un bijoux de la collection patrimoniale
de la bibliothèque départementale
il s'agit de la relation du voyage de
percer des indes orientales
d'un auteur qui s'appelle thomas cerbère
et c'est un ouvrage qui date de 1663
c'est le premier récit de voyage qui
parle de la réunion thomas certes était
un anglais qui avaient été envoyés par
le roi l'angleterre pour naviguer sur
les mers et dans cette branche vous
voyez qu'il est très ancien il parle de
livres de la réunion parce que lors de
son voyage il passe par maurice il
s'arrête à la réunion et il rend compte
à la fois de ce qu'ils trouvent à la
réunion il rend compte aussi des
différents noms qu'on pu avoir la
réunion donc je vais vous montrer les
branches concernées que c'est vraiment
quelques lignes dans un ouvrage bien
plus important mais c'est absolument
fondamental pour la connaissance de la
réunion donc pendant leur périple qui
s'arrête sur une île qu'ils appellent
l'île de la forêt une angleterre
pourquoi parce que la réunion est
tellement vert tellement touffue que mon
lui avait donnés par le passé le nom de
l'île de la forêt l'angleterre et r
verte dit aussi qu entre temps lille
c'est aussi appelé
de mascarin puisqu'il y avait un
navigateur portugais qui s'appelait
mascarenhas qui était bien passée par là
et dit également qu on l'appelle tous
nos pulls à ce qui veut dire qu'au xviie
siècle au début du xviie moitié 17e il
ya déjà trois noms pour la réunion
mascarin pour le boulard et l'île de la
forêt d'angleterre et la description qui
et de la réunion à cette époque est
formidable puisqu'il dit que c'est une
île donc je voulais dit très vert avec
beaucoup d'arbres il n'y a pas d'autres
créatures sur cette île que des oiseaux
et il parle de l'eau bouddhique l'eau
est en profusion sur l'île qu'elle est
fort bonne et en grande quantité dick a
énormément de poissons des anguilles et
que finalement c'est avec regret qu'il
quitte saisi l'on chante et donc la
réunion et mon fils pour reprendre
l'océan
moi